pues una jornada siempre candente cuando
se trata de la Reforma pensional allí en
la asamblea nacional El Debate lo abrió
Valeria jabón ella es diputada
socialista de la coalición de izquierda
nupes explicando que era necesaria esta
nueva moción de censura debido al
descrédito del que ha sido víctima la
asamblea nacional por como el gobierno
hizo todo ese proceso de la Reforma
pensional aprobando por decreto la
reforma sin necesidad del voto de la
asamblea a esto respondió Elizabeth la
primera ministra presente aquí en la
asamblea diciendo que pues su gobierno
era un gobierno valiente ante esas
críticas tan Aviva voz por parte de la
oposición y criticó también a la
oposición diciendo que era de alguna
manera bastante incoherente lo que
hacían en vista de que además en esta
moción de censura pues se querían y
tuvieron el apoyo de reagrupación
nacional la extrema derecha en todo caso
los votos no fueron suficientes a lo
largo de toda esta hora de debate media
hora tuvieron después para votar
finalmente les Faltaron 50 votos para
poder tener esa mayoría absoluta que es
de 289 y que esto pudiera ser aprobada y
pues bueno una vez más como usted lo
decía ya es la número 17 en un año de
gobierno y Elizabeth bound que sigue
salvándose más cuando en estos últimos
tiempos se habla tanto de los posibles
cambios que puede haber en el gabinete
Ministerial de Manuel